okay for people joining this
live stream i think this is a very live
stream day for me
um we are doing a review of
visualization functionality
for the upcoming version of language and
we've got a variety of topics here
um and somebody who
should be on mute isn't
okay stream plot
3d
i don't know we've had a stream plot for
millions of years we've had vector plot
3d
but we've not had stream plot 3d is that
right correct
is this design complicated or is this
straightforward it's a vector field in
three dimensions
the design i mean the syntax is the same
as vector plot 3d
it's straightforward stephen there's
nothing weird okay but this is the point
is it's it's integrating i don't
remember lagrangian versus whatever
fluid mechanics thing what is this doing
this is this is integrating along
streamlines basically
yes so what happens i mean if i
if i make a bar magnet if i make a
dipole field for example
will i see
okay those are monopole fields
okay
why is there all this extra crud here
um don't know
because he specified a lot of controls
so there's a couple of points in and
controlling how the streamlines look and
controlling
you know a little bit what the density
of them is and
and there's two balls red balls for them
yeah okay that's interesting i never
really internalized that you could make
a lawrence attractor as a pure stream
plot
because this is x dot y dot z dot or
something
yes
i see so does it for an autonomous
yeah you know for an autonomous system
of
differential equations you can always do
this
so if i were to take this
and just do the default
how i the thing i'm trying to understand
each streamline
this is what i'm getting at
that's pretty nice but now so
it has some automatic choice of the
number of streamlines
i was going through a you know small
grid in each direction
but if i was to change this three
i mean is this scale independent or is
this going to change things
it's still going to be the same number
of stream lines basically
you know i mean conceivably it could
behave differently because you know it
hits the boundary in a slightly
different way or something
but not for this case
well what i mean is when it probably oh
yeah it goes in and out spluffle
well i mean the other thing is that the
integration has
you know sort of a fixed number you know
distance that it goes forward and
backwards
that's what i was wondering about right
this doesn't look right if it's a
streamline it should be a streamline
not a piece of a streamline
but it hits the boundary it doesn't hit
the boundary no there's stuff that's not
hitting the boundaries
look at that there's interior stuff
that's broken
oh i didn't see that interior stuff
something's wrong here i mean this
functionality in general is lovely but
something is wrong with your with your
heuristic for
how long the integration should be
right
we'll take a look at that and we
probably still need
some sort of control to manually
override with the
integration length is sure
now what happens if i put in more
streamlines is there a way how do i how
do i say how many street lines that
should be
stream points
that was interesting why did it yeah
flip that side doesn't seem right
and that doesn't seem like it's i mean
if i if i say stream points to a hundred
okay that's harrier
and i assume that it makes no sense to
have some opacity to these lines yeah it
makes no sense
never mind bad idea and what happens if
i say mesh goes to all does it start
putting little
i mean if i wanted to see the the don't
think it has mesh supported yet
okay because that would be a nice thing
to see because if you're you're along
the stream line it's
like how fast are you going along that
stream line
right the idea is to color them like we
do for stream plot
that's not in here how come well i mean
it's being normalized out in this case
what does that mean what is the coloring
normally
um it's the magnitude
i see but here these are unit vectors
right
oh yeah well okay but there's two
different things there's the magnitude
of the vector
and there's as you go along the stream
in the
you know how does it you get what i'm
saying
but the magnitude determines the speed
i guess that's right
and this would be too consistent with
the coloring we use for vector plot
vector plot 3d
stream plot and so on all right okay
okay okay
what does it look like if you use um um
uh what's it you know mesh points
for um you got what i'm saying
for um
um stream points yeah
right no no if you use mesh points to
show the speed rather than colors
it won't be a super good measure okay
it's it's all right it will be some
measure but it's
it's it has a bunch of other phenomena
there too
okay vector plot 3d over regions
magnificent but i don't think i doubt i
need to look at it
no i don't think so geograph that sounds
interesting
and so this is you know graph plot on
geode not
you know pulling out yes it is not what
you consider geograph that is
pulling the you know connectivity of
roads and stuff outside of
you know out of our vector maps type
stuff
right by the way christopher pointed out
that we actually need another thing with
geo and all this other stuff
we need a a geo raster
in which every pixel in the raster
is a projected region on the earth
so i'm saying which is something we
don't have and we have geoimage which is
doing the other way around but anyway
that's a
thing okay geographic so so this
is from city to city to city exactly
i mean it can be many things that you
can represent with it
but did you ask for a specific example
or
well no no i was i was just trying to
understand what and what happens if you
go from a country to a country
it right i mean it will you know
you know so if you have a you know edge
that's from the uk to the us
it will currently look at what is
you know what geo position gives for
each of those things which is some
central location
and connect those
okay um i mean there's an example in
applications that shows
this sort of thing um i think it's in
like orthographic projection or
something
down at the bottom
is jose here by the way i don't think he
is
i can invite him if
seems useful this is a very non-trivial
thing here
it's interesting
so what you're saying is
i mean by the way find shortest tour
and all those kinds of things you're now
suggesting that those should be
returning graphs
maybe you can do that you just say find
shorter store of graph of
i don't know does that work no that
doesn't work yes it does
no it doesn't because you don't have if
all you've got is a bag of
points a bag of cities
right
then i'm short of stuart works on on
graphs
but you're thinking something else i'm
thinking i want
these cities and you know if i say find
shortest tour
it's kind of a good demo you can find
the shortest tour between those cities
right
which we could now represent as a graph
here
we are representing it as just a you
know
geo-list plot type thing
right i mean graph itself doesn't know
anything about geo
yeah i think it's what you're getting at
so you know find shortest tour would
you mean you would have to specify like
the distance function or something
like how to yeah i see
well okay so i mean aren't there all
kinds of
options for the for the driving distance
and all that kind of thing
yeah i think there's just like you know
what the method is i don't think we have
i mean you can look at travel directions
or whatever it is
um which is we should get jose here
i i sent him email um
so
i expect he will probably join us
shortly unless he's
at lunch or something okay
i don't know if he's taking lunches
quite this late these days but
i don't know spanish rules
um but anyways this can represent quite
a lot of relations
you know which is a new class of
visualizations that we haven't had
yes indeed look i mean i
i think i mean one example that
um comes to mind if i pull it up
is um you know like people going from
one country to another
and and then you can have thickness of
those lines represented
that we consider to be sort of a
follow-on to this
with flows when we when we have sizes
and stuff
so we we we want to continue with that
post this this is pure
relations because there's a whole world
of
of ways of dealing with that too
right there's an application example
that's not quite that but it's
along those lines yeah so what is the
automatic setting for whether it's
straight or whether it's curved
do um so by default it's
you know essentially doing the same as
graph plot and so
um whatever graph plot gives us
is what we use um
and so i mean actually it's looking like
um and so like it may you know by
default it will get like that one that
you have at the top it's straight lines
except that if you were to introduce you
know a duplicate edge
or a self loop or something then it
would get curvature
um you know and it would
i see self loop obviously is going to
have things but this is kind of weird
hijacking of graph layout which is
normally things like spring electrical
i mean it's a little bit weird hijack i
mean
it is a hijacking of graph layout but i
think why why would that be weird
what don't you want because yeah but you
can't do spring electrical embedding on
you you just pinned a bunch of cities
well i mean so if you look at the docs
for graph layouts
it actually allows you to say you know
what's the layout for the vertices
yeah it's the layout for the edges that
makes sense
by the way ethan on our live stream is
talking about edge bundling
for large graphs and i agree that that's
interesting
we're we're looking into that so we're
looking into that but
it at the moment those bundling layouts
only work you know when it also is
allowed to move the vertices around
um you know it's a combo thing and so
as soon as we lock the vertices down you
know as you know because they have
actual locations
then those layouts uh tend not to do
anything interesting at the moment
so but but agreed that bundling methods
is you know absolutely going to be you
know
stuff that we want
um okay is there anything else i should
look at it
looks like a very lovely function
um again i think that the um region to
region thing
i suspect you want different kinds of
arrows oh look at the self loops
interesting okay um is it is it running
in this version here
it's running in that version um
when i was trying stuff this morning
the external build i was using had
trouble seeming to get
geo positions from entities
which hello
hey jose hello have you looked at joe
um graph plot jose not much we have
discussed it a bit but not much
this isn't useful what i'm doing here
what i need to do is i need to have
a graph right so i need this
arrow london
and then i need something like
london arrow sydney
works for you yay
well the magnificent they've got the
north pole as well and what what
projection is that
how does it get to the north i guess it
could be anywhere up
line it seems like a rectangular
okay so if i say
if i if i do the following if i say
random graph
of 20 comma 40
and then i say how do i how do i label
those with with [ __ ]
with them do vertex replace
um no no vertex replace of the graph
yeah yeah
over to i meant to do that
um and then i want to say the
table i goes to
random geo position you know i goes up
to 20.
cool
why doesn't anything go back behind the
earth
you got lucky
it reminds me
[Music]
um this is using a straight line so
perhaps you have to say geopath in some
place no
what happened it went behind the earth
and didn't get
picked up on the other side um that's
the bug we know about
actually this is you know probably
related to the discussion earlier today
about jose's
longitudinal mod stuff no i know i know
i know i know
that's okay so if i do this percent
eleven
and then i do um uh how do i do like
your center goes to zero zero
no no no graph layout can i do
um like great circles what are those
called um
current geodesic
that needs autocomplete by the way yup
oh that's lovely
wonder why we don't have a vertex at
oh oh oh that's what's it
it seems to be cutting at the date line
right everything beyond the design
yeah but we've got one that's going into
canada
yes probably because it's handled i mean
the points
and the circles and the edges are
handled separately apparently
i mean but so is that like one line
that's
like going into canada and then coming
back out
yes why do we yes it's being routed to
canada for some reason
sounds like some packages i've shipped
over the years
um let's let's take
so okay there's something goofy going on
look at all of these
yeah that is interesting i mean it may
have something to do with the dateline
quite possibly um
so if i say this geoprojection
i mean if you set geocenter then oh i
don't want to do that i'm not there
okay where is it it's all on the back
side of the
map that's crazy okay geocenter
so okay there's some bugs here yes
you're centered to zero zero
let's set it to null island what
you don't know about that roger no no
island is a fictional piece of land zero
zero
oh i mean is it something we made up or
is it the face no no it has a wikipedia
page an intro
everything oh i think you can do your
position of knight
eye length
i wonder what's happening with
orthographic um
i guess we're at a point where it's time
to take a graph and run it through every
projection and see what breaks
it yeah it may be one of these cases in
which because one point fails
it decides to remove the whole thing
it's possible
um okay
well so okay so there's some bugs here
so let's just take
for one thing let me just take something
here just for fun i just want to try one
thing here
um
see whether it actually takes a
realistic time so if i say geoposition
let's say continental
united states is that a thing
is that going to work doesn't seem right
what is that i mean it'll probably give
you stuff in north america based on
what's that doing i don't even
understand what that did okay so let's
say
geograph plot
okay great okay
what i mean what
it looks like it's greenland up there it
is greenland
but that presumably is is the the
continent of the united states is north
america and greenland is part of that
plate
right okay so then
then what i want to do
um geodesic
or digital driving
is this going to work what's it going to
do with greenland
yeah it's supposed to fall back to like
a geodesic
oh that's interesting
coordinate failed should be a pair of
numbers
um
okay anyway this is really cool very
nice
um
let's see ethan is commenting about
geojson i thought we had geojson
and toppo json thought we had those
formats we do we do
have a do we have a couple json
not topper json we have a geojson
okay um
let's see does geograph accept graphs
with vertices given as explicit geo
positions
that's an interesting question
geographics yes you can put a graph
directly into geographics
say with entities
yeah but i think what's being asked is
if the if
these values
were if these names of these vertices
were geo positions not entities would
that work and it should
obviously um that's what you're doing
right now okay fine
because that's what random geoposition
is giving you when you're doing your
protection
fine fine um
okay the question here was if there are
many vertices will it scale down the
vertex markers
so that they're what seems to be
sculling down just fine i mean it's
dealing with the image size i don't know
if it's scaling with the number of
vertices
okay that's a question and and do we
think
that this rendering which is after all
different from how we normally render a
plot
we're doing this rendering so that it's
more visible on top of geo
backgrounds is that correct correct
okay so for example if i say geograph
percent
18 i think we're not 100
we're not 100 sure whether red is the
right
i mean it's a thing that shows up
against every background but
looks okay now what happens if we do um
i see we're too zoomed out to do so if
we were to do the same thing here
um and we just did to say
uh random geo position of
i don't know singapore
okay i think it looks pretty decent i
mean the red looks pretty decent by
default
why is there no labeling on the
singapore
because the gene of is functions turn
off labels
um on the background map by default how
do i get labels on the background map
uh geo background goes to street label
or a street map
oh 22.
those still kind of worked or maybe i
just looked away at the wrong moment
oh this would yeah okay so
if i now say geo layout
no i'm sorry graph layout
arrow driving
then stuff should line up
one hopes
it's taking its time all right
well okay i admit there's some things
that were hot now
it's a shame we can't get to that guy
and there's this there's some bug here
with the with these ones that didn't
make it from driving
right um there's something fishy going
on right there
this is i don't understand this oh maybe
i see it's getting to the closest place
it can get to
yes i'm thinking that several will route
over the same road segment
yes i mean that is absolutely happening
and
it's an interesting effect having the
red lines on top of the orange lines and
it just makes it look like a really
thick red line somehow
i like this i think this is looking
really good
i think it's really good i mean the
sizes of the white dots
i'm not so sure about but um this is
good
okay let's move on um
list line plot 3d
oh my gosh there's a comment from p
winkler and geosmooth histogram with
weighted data and associations going to
be fixed
even the examples of the documentation
scope data weighted data
don't work anymore well i think i saw a
bug report about that
earlier this week so we'll take a look
at it
okay can you indicate edge
types in mixed graphs
by the way i mean this is yes
the answer is yes okay but but i've got
a question here
if i say um how do i turn this into a
directed graph i guess i can just say
um how do i make that do i just say
direct i don't know what happens if i
just say direct to graph but if i say
graph
rule attack
[Music]
you can make there is a directed graph i
understand it but what does it do if you
if you have a
it will make a directory graph it will
it i mean it's there's many ways you can
do it
what just happened it crashed
system crashed wow
[Music]
by the way it would be a nice thing
perhaps for a random graph to be able to
have
a way to label it to pick the vertices
from some set
like i'm doing here
um there is a graph distribution that
does that
however this is just the the simplest
possible graph distribution that you use
for random graph
no i think he means to choose the
vertices from a set
yeah to control you know that it's not
just
integers one to n right because in this
case i want a random graph between
cities yeah but there's a geometric
graph distribution
what do you mean i mean i i wanted to i
just want one where i've got the same
random graph i just want the random
graph those arrows don't make it
no yeah we'll take a look at that uh tim
you got a screenshot of that
i've got it in time stamped okay
excellent
um
okay no but roger what i'm saying is i
want a random graph i want it with this
connectivity but i want the names of the
vertices not to be one two three four
oh oh just like symbolic names
not not where there or you know he gives
a list of entities
up front and says create a random graph
from these
right yeah i think it's something when i
say we should
it's not a bad idea i mean it's a very
yeah absolutely okay
all right so can somebody take that and
maybe
i mean are there notes coming out from
this right there's someone taking notes
yes perfect and they've been good you
know sending stuff off to them yeah they
have so
it's been working okay let's line plot
3d
what's the point here um
the point is to have
you know a 3d version of list line plot
you know the
you know list version of parametric plot
3d
um but how do
you're saying making it splining it or
something or what no that one's not
splined it's just
relatively well sampled
um and so so in the xyz you know if you
give triples then you get
you know sort of um
the parametric you know curve type
approach
um and then the other one is if you give
a
you know a ray of heights then it's
doing it as
you know basically slices and joining
them in one direction
array of heights
it's getting slices what right so
so each row is turned into you know
essentially a
list line plot and each this line plot
live
let me see if i understand it even the
most basic way so what you're saying is
if i say angle path 3d
of random real
i don't know minus 1 1 comma 20.
uh do you need
why is it saying that does it need to be
three-dimensional in some way
oh yes i think you need 20 22.
what's up change the 20 to 20 comma 2.
uh in a list in upper
okay and then we've got list
line plot 3d
oh cool now
list line 3d we haven't had this before
no at least point plot 3d but not this
line plot 3 right and
originally this came out of you know
wanting to add a joined option to list
point plot3d
okay by the way this is a good source of
examples if you don't have it already
angle
that is a good source for examples um
okay okay so now let me understand your
other case so this is the case i
understand this is this is showing
joining up every point now
so the other case is when you aren't
giving x y z coordinates where you're
just giving a bunch of heights
so you're just giving a bunch of z
coordinates yes
okay and you interpret in each row of z
coordinates
as a path
i don't understand from the base
do you think it is okay do
[Music]
list line plot 3d maybe uh look at the
documentation here
third example
i don't freaking get it oh you mean you
mean it's it's a bunch of lines in the x
direction
it's a it's not an uncommon section so
that first
row 2.1 2.9 etc oh i i get what this is
now i get what this is so i mean so
basically what you're saying is
if i were to just get if i would just
take um
you know if you were to do this line
plot of that
everything has the same profile yeah
right
yes just like andy
okay all right i get it well it's useful
yeah it's nice actually it's quite nice
okay any other choices for this function
not really um i mean a follow-on from
this is that we're going to use this to
implement joined for the feature space
plots
what would joined and feature space plot
do yeah what would that do
you're the one who requested it i'm
pretty sure
but what would it do
okay nick is commenting this will make a
nice 3d version of distribution chart
and by the way whoever's got
clinking in the background it'd be nice
to mute sorry
yes um yeah that comment is great we we
noticed that too it's a
it's a great way to show um
distributions
so each curve could be a piece let's say
i get it i get it with different
parameter values
yeah right which is i think what's you
know um i think we got a request from
emerald for this you know type of
functionality for that purpose
uh last year at some point okay
all right let's look at these and we're
going to run out of time
so um axis object
so the basic idea the real name but yeah
so there's many reasons but one key
reason is to do
multiple axis plots
um and not just two axes multiple access
points so what's the relationship
between this
and a scale that you put on a geographic
or something like that which is a
floating creature
this can be used as that right i mean
this would
you know replace i mean this would go
into
you know how geoscale bar is implemented
yeah well this is nice so then how do we
get
that's nice but but we want to be able
to get these outer frame
axes to be this also an axis object
that would i mean i mean
i'm open to figuring out how to
well i would say that the obvious thing
to do is to say frame text arrow
and then give an access object
see what i'm saying i think that would
work i mean
i would be fine with that syntax so you
allow
this object to be you know this
construct to be used as
ticks and frame ticks is what
you're saying right
um in in which case you know we can
you know you lied the first argument or
whatever
um this is something that you know the
frame and axis things remain
positional sorry sorry sorry i spaced
out for one second could you repeat
right i mean so at the moment the axis
object has
besides all the tick controls it has
information about
where to draw it and you know how the
scale is on that curve from that path
right so we'll have to write that out
right the case where it's self-placed
yes
i mean i would argue think about an
arrow
right arrow has you know what we do is
we wrap
arrow around the line object
i think we should do the same thing here
because i can imagine some scale you
know one day where we want a curved
scale or something
around a circle let's say
right we don't need that but people
might want that in the future an angular
scale
this one supports curb scales well you
understand that but i'm saying that the
syntax what i'm suggesting is instead of
doing this
to do basically axis object or something
of line of blah blah blah
right just like arrow does that arrow
you know we had imagined i mean i think
it's a more flexible way to do it and it
will work
actually it is in some ways more
flexible
i mean the question is this is easier
you know is it easier to then say you
know this point on the arrow is zero
and this point on the arrow is ten maybe
not
okay so look here we've got arrow with
two points
okay and then it also allows a curve all
right so i guess we
are both in that case so that we can
have an arrow that is a tube
so maybe what you need is something
where you are specifying
the mapping from um
uh let's just see how you do this
this is an important function
i don't understand why you say
horizontal and vertical i mean i would
have just thought it was left right
something in other words
you're putting the thing it's got some
rule that says
if you go from a to b
if you're if you if you have if the
scale goes from a to b
is it up relative to that or down
relative to that
do you see what i'm saying i see what
you're saying
um this one is so far not specifying
that it's just specifying
i know i know i know i know but if you
go in line from point to point
you could have this so you could have
the flip around of that where the
where the the whiskers are down are down
rather than yeah well i mean but that's
separate
no that's a separate control yeah it's a
separate control
um i mean so if you look at the diagram
at the top
you know so along the axis
we define left and right you know as you
go from
small values to large values and then we
have
operations it's just from
one coordinate value to another
coordinate value
right no i think it really is going
small to large
that it's not necessarily going you know
first to second
okay um which i mean maybe you know
i mean it could be um
trying to think if that
is any easier to parameter okay listen
practical point i have another meeting
coming up and um
we this is this going to make it to 12
for 12 3 this axis object thing
a second the plan is for it to be
experimental in 12 3.
okay as i think we're going to include
and so
part of what we want to do is to to have
transitions quite a lot of functionality
to use it before we make it
um non-experimental so we iron out all
the
a lot of the issues so this is going to
look i think this design is going to
take a solid half hour
to do this axis object design so i
recommend that we try and reschedule
this for tomorrow
uh actually tomorrow is really bad for
me but maybe the next day
yeah okay we can do that and uh
and then just as a preview for a second
um
what is this
what is this so the big idea
is that there is a whole lot of scales
in the world
that's used for psychological testing
product ratings medical testing
that are not quantitative i understand
so you want to be able to take data
which has
which is which has um things in those
scales and map those into coordinates
exactly
yep yeah non-numeric scaling functions
yes so bond ratings for instance this is
like a product rating
yup you know
egg i've learned about egg ratings do
you know what those are
egg ratings yes like you're a triple a
grade egg ah double a not triple a sorry
there's double a a and b okay well
meat has apparently eight different
scales i mean
grades i'm sure it does i'm sure fruit
has lots of grades and
all kinds of other oh yeah it's a big
world of
things that we do and the question is
whether you know if when the chicken was
laying the egg it was listening to
a mozart then it gets an extra little
piece of plumage
that's what we need
right um
okay all right
uh well interesting all right i look
forward to this
um great so why don't we schedule we
need another hour for these
these two the axis stuff and these
nominal scale things okay i'm looking at
friday you said
i think so i mean i'll just just just
find out
um okay that's good see you all soon
thanks a lot